you're so good at that by the way a
perfect height man uh it was so
beautiful to watch you dance again
tonight
[Music]
[Music]
it felt so good to just be back and know
I'm being a witness for these finalists
and I get to just go out to dance to
Jordan it was like a dream come true
there's a first thing I said when I met
Jordan like I hope one day I could never
dance to you not not thinking I could
and then we got to it was such a thrill
I mean this was an incredible season it
full of so much representation feels
like such a momentous season I don't
know if it's just me because it's the
only one I was on but but it's one that
we needed it was a really beautiful one
and Shangela and Glenn killed it tonight
like that brought the house down we were
roaring it was such a good performance I
mean all of them good but Shangela
really brings the fun I'll never forget
the week that you had to leave the
competition it was emotional and it was
almost hard to watch but it was also
inspiring what do you hope people take
away from your story and watching you on
Dancing With the Stars this season no it
was a beautiful thing to join and I
loved it so much and I was I was crushed
to leave
but it was important to take care of
myself I have more going on you know I'm
not a professional dancer my career does
not hinge on that I had to take care of
my bones
and Arthur and I have Arthur but um you
know it was so beautiful to be
applauded and still say it's okay like
you're it's okay to bow out you know
there there are other dancers here we
all love so it's lovely and I was so
humbled to have that kindness of
everyone just send me off you know so it
makes you feel like you won for a night
you know you know it's so special
speaking of so special it was amazing to
see show for Christina Applegate at her
Hollywood Walk of Fame ceremony why was
it important for you to be there oh gosh
I've known Christina for so many years
we're really close actually and I'm just
one I'm a fan of hers I've been she is
an iconic iconic California girl actress
of my generation and she is it there's
not been one thing that she's done that
I haven't been like nailed at right and
she's nailing just being who she is with
this Ms like she was funny and
definitely like her performance was
amazing but to be there I just want to
witness the greats in my friends lives
like just quietly back there and so to
know I was there for something that like
we dream about when we're little of
course and how have you been supporting
her through her Ms battle oh my God
Christina still supports me like she's
just such a strong one she really is
she's such a nurturer if you need
something she's at your house there have
been things that I've been unglued and
she's like I'm outside answer the door
she's she's just amazing and strong and
fun but um you know I'm more like okay
if you need help with canes and that
stuff because I'm like really into all
that like all the things that help me
like get around but she's she's getting
it locked down you know she has she has
a lot on her plate it's a lot but she's
she's as brilliant and beautiful as ever
[Music]
thank you